well hey everybody Merry Christmas yeah
why are you laughing at
me he's always laughing at me I don't
know why was fun I don't know why I do
that so funny all the time uh but yeah
Merry Christmas everybody hope you had a
good one yep we're going to review two
movies today that are kind of well the
weird thing about it is that Ginger dead
man it's not clear whether it's set on
Christmas or not but I guess cuz it's
gingerbread men then it's still kind of
christmy and then the second movie the
brain is absolutely set at Christmas
time although that doesn't super factor
into the plot all that much but that's
okay out of the two I like the brain a
lot better that was almost like a
Cronenberg flick yeah a lot of good
ideas it did yes I can't believe I
didn't see this movie me too I don't
know how I like this I don't know how I
miss missed it yeah ging gingerbread
Ginger dead man Gary booy's in
it doing what he does boying up the
place and he's only in he's only in it
he's really only in it for like the
first [__] 10 15 minutes does a
stunning performance like he does then
from then on out he's just the voice of
this monster yeah if you want to call it
it kind of looks like him but I kind of
got the teeth right
yeah but those are pretty distinctive
you know what I mean other than that
it's just like a '90s horror flip even
though it came out in 2005 was it 2005
yeah it felt like a ' 90s horor flip
kind it did kind of um although you're
right 2005 the girls had white belts and
little pink belts and their pants and
[__] and cute hair you know it it was
that early 2000s look it did have cute
girls in it that's that's about it it
was just tacky it was it was it was
entertaining yeah it was
entertaining
um by today's standards a lot better
than
like some of the [__] crappy be
movies that you'd find you know by you
know by troma or something you know it
was better than that it at least had
some
artistic talent to it they
tried the thing about it yeah the ginger
dead man this was actually Charles band
this one who's you know he's real famous
for doing these kind of bee movies like
this and and the movie I didn't even
realize both of these are on shutter
actually if you have shutter they're in
the unhappy holidays
section um this movie is only 71 minutes
long and you can tell that there was a
lot of padding in there because as cool
as it was when the when the ginger dead
man finally comes to life and starts
rampaging around um I didn't realize
that there was going to be so much of
like a love triangle story in there too
yeah like between the the girl at the
bakery and then the delinquent guy and
the and the [__] girl yeah and her dad
and her dad and yeah I and another thing
I didn't realize until I looked up the
notes like looked up the Wikipedia page
afterward is like all the characters had
like the main the main girl that worked
at the bakery her name was Sarah Lee you
know like you know what I mean and then
like the delinquent last name was
cadberry yeah okay and then like the guy
that owned the place across the street
was named Jimmy Dean you know like the
sausage or whatever and um so they all
had like yeah so they all had those kind
of names now here's the thing thing um
the ginger dead man is a great concept I
kind of feel like all I haven't seen
like a [__] ton of Charles bands movies
but all of the ones I've seen it's like
they always come up with like a really
good concept but I always feel like the
concepts are way funnier than the
execution ends up being yeah you know
what I mean it's like back in the
80s back in the VHS days where you and
your friends would go down to [__]
you know [__]
Blockbuster or what was the other one
nighttime video is that the other one
nighttime video no um was was the other
one the show Showtime show I don't
remember one movie gallery you could get
R-rated and x-rated movies there at that
one yeah um well they would at that that
particular that particular uh rental
place they had kind of like the harder
slashers type movies and um kind of
reminds me when I when I was a kid back
in the
80s every time a new movie would come
out it would have some kind of gimmicky
premise you know what I mean of where
the monster came from and it was the
same kind of contrivances but it was
different it was different every time
you know what I mean and then this one
the idea is is that a serial killer who
wiped out a bunch of people played by uh
booy he uh gets electrocuted on the on
the uh [__] electric
chair and somehow his ashes end up in a
pack a [__] gingerbread spice mix
they imply that his mom put them in
there yeah his mom like cuz she's a
witch or something right which okay
whatever and the spice mix gets used in
a
bakery where
uh it's owned by the survivors of one
has massacres
right so the spice mix gets used in some
dough which gingerbread men are not made
out of dough but that's what they made
you know that's what we were because
we're looking at it going bread dough
that's bread dough that is clearly not
gingerbread it's like not even the same
consistency and I love too that she
spreads out cuz the blood dripped in it
too cuz of course that also had to work
yeah so I love how she spread the dough
out and then she had one gingerbread man
cookie cutter that was big
T it was like tall as like a Barbie doll
or something she makes like one thing
and then Tes all the dough and I don't
know if she threw it away but I was like
so you're after all that you're just
going to make oneck and she's going to
put that in the big industrial oven just
the one so they bake it and it comes out
looking like [__] [__] Gary gooy
and everything with his face and [__]
and it's his face and his voice and he
comes out it's kind of like Chucky he's
I was going to say this is very this is
pretty much exactly like Child's Play
like like because Child's Play that was
also a serial killer and he like
transferred his soul into the doll you
know it's like Chucky it's the same kind
of thing except he's a gingerbread man
yeah running around and he's got a face
that looks a little bit like [__]
bruy yeah and but it's definitely his
voice coming out and it's just a horror
slasher comedy there isn't a lot of
action in it but it does have some you
know what I mean it [__] does happen but
it it's padded out a little bit with
with like love stories and cute girl
girls and [__] that's just what you're
supposed to do no nudity in I was going
to say no nudity no nudity which is not
a true 80s it's not it's not a true
deformed ' 80s or 90s [__] they would
have thrown the nudity in there they
would no reason to have girls in any
slasher movie if they're not going to
take their tops off that's was kind of
yeah that's why you were watching that's
and they yeah they knew that that they
knew so yeah so if you see a slasher
with no titties in it you're just like
kind of feel ripped off you know what I
mean right by the time 2004 was around
there was already internet porn so the
demand wasn't there right yeah it's not
quite the same thing we didn't have porn
back then so you know you you couldn't
buy the magazines you were underage you
had to take it where you but you could
rent this [__] you know what I mean
[__] you can R rent it at [__]
Blockbuster and see some titties go yeah
man y they look nice all right Ted yeah
yeah you can talk about them that's
that's what teenage boys did B sat
around reading the titties
yeah and most girls had no interest in
these movies although they would watch
them with you yeah yeah but I don't
think Jen was one of the girl liked them
but I think most most girls didn't like
them slashers aren't my favorite sub
genre of horror but I I like them I
think they're fun yeah I like all kind
of horror movies pretty
much but you know I'm kind of I like
supernatural horror I like haunted house
type [__] psychological horror stuff but
I like slashers too if I'm in the mood
you know what I mean the ones that
started them for me were like cronberg
movies yeah and then it got into like
the Lovecraft movies with you know
reanimator and from Beyond animator 2
and um Hellraiser a little bit but then
the early F uh Friday the 13th yeah once
uh the Freddy Krueger movies yeah night
Street yeah and Child's
Play just [__] like that you know Fright
Night Fright Night that was one of my
favorite movies in the '
80s but yeah so I mean okay so like I
said I kind of feel like this one you're
going to love this cuz I was like like I
know Ginger dead man has a sequel it
does in fact have two direct sequels uh
Ginger Dead Man 2 The Passion of the
crust yeah we saw that one we didn't
watch no we didn't watch it but yeah we
saw the advertisement for and then um
part three is called Saturday night
Cleaver okay and the ginger dead man
goes back in time like to the Disco era
and starts killing people does the voice
I don't know actually I don't know if
Gary beasy was in the funny thing about
it it said I was reading about this on
Wikipedia
and they said that Charles band like
actually went to Gary Bucy and offered
him $25,000 to do the movie and he
didn't think he would do it cuz he
didn't think it would be enough but he's
just like okay yeah oh yeah if I can do
it in one day I can be in and out of
there I'll do all the voice AC don't
call me back here I got to go back to
the
bar I'll do it I'll do that's probably
what happened yeah and one thing about
Boo is uh he's been in a lot of movies
that that he played a lot of roles that
I liked like the uh in in in that
Crustle flick U [__] Soldier oh yeah
yeah he was in that he played a good
character well [__] uh he play in
that one of my favorite Steven cull
movies [__] Under Siege yeah that's
right and one thing about booy is that
he doesn't phone the [__] in he [__]
chews up the whole [__] scenery well
that's why you get Gary get Gary booy
you're GNA get your money worth out
of he's a [__] trip just see Silver
Bullet that's when he was at he was at
he was at his Zenith he was at his buest
the most buest of all
and his son is good too we just saw him
last night [__] The Frighteners we
rewatched The Frighteners again last
night which has so great yeah if you see
the the uh director's Edition on Blu-ray
man it it that that cut is [__]
awesome that movie is a
masterpiece yeah we love that movie yeah
so yeah we watched that again last night
we were drinking on Christmas and his
son man he booies the [__] out that too
yeah yeah he was also in Nazis Nazis at
the center of the earth he was good at
that that's right yeah yeah we never did
review that did we or did we I think
maybe we did I don't remember if we did
or not that was a good movie too but
yeah so and okay so then like
documentary so they did those two
sequels they were going to do another
one that was going to be called rebaked
but they never did make it but then
there there there's a whole bunch of
crossover movies with um evil bong so
there's Ginger Dead Man versus evil bong
and then I think there's two other ones
where there's like a crossover and
there's also comic series which is
called baking bad and I was just
like this is what I mean about like the
concept for these and like the the
titles and stuff are like way funnier
than the movie ends up being yeah this
does have its moments but um I feel like
if you're going to have a movie called
The Ginger dead man about like a little
killer gingerbread man then I think it
needed to lean harder into that conceit
I mean I guess they couldn't afford it
and budget problem sure I mean the whole
thing is shot in one room essentially
well not well no that's not true but
it's shot about like it was shot in a
bakery and around the bakery yeah and
there's and whenever they have like an
establishing shots of the bakery it's
obvious that the bakery sign is just a
[__] tarp over the real sign with a
hand painted [__] cheap looking sign
cuz the first time I saw that sign I was
like
o that sign is so bad yeah looks like it
was done by a teenage
girl finger paint yeah it's like it
looked like Boutique or something like
that it's terrible DVD Dragon said Gary
buy probably wanted to snort the flower
LOL yeah he probably did yeah maybe
that's what maybe he did maybe he did
when they weren't looking you know whaty
probably did this [__] in two days two
three days I well yeah because really
the only scene that he's in like with
his face opening scene is the opening
scene where he blows all his people away
in the diner um and then you don't see
him again you just hear his voice so I
imagine they probably could do that well
[__] man that one scene they probably
just shot that in a [__] hour yeah
probably shot probably shot him in in
one day yeah I would imagine then did
the voiceovers because it doesn't really
seem and honestly there's you know the
he's in it and he says funny [__] but
it's like he's not in it a lot you know
what I mean cuz like I said I didn't
realize how much of the movie was going
to be taken up with Sarah Lee the you
know the girl that runs the bakery and
her budding romance with the delinquent
guy who was what was his name a Amos but
his last name was Cadbury yeah this is
supposed to be happening in Texas yeah
wo Texas yeah so there's a bunch of
southernisms going on and you can tell
that some of the actors are not
Southerners they're they're fake in
it but I think I think the the star of
the show I think that one girl that does
s that is that was a convincing southern
accent yeah she might be from the south
she might have just been Hamming it up a
little bit Robin Sydney I think her name
was yeah the dark-haired girl you mean
like the main act the the main actress
she did that she did sound
sou Tammy said do they have a Little
Debbie no but they should have yeah damn
it missed opportunity maybe well I don't
know maybe in some of the sequels I
don't know if I'd want to watch the
sequels though because I thought I
probably feel like the titles are
funnier than the actual cuz as soon as I
saw that the second one was called
Passion of the crust I was like okay
that's pretty funny but I don't I don't
know if the movie can live up to that
you know what I mean but it's just kind
of like I don't know so I liked it it
was fun it was entertaining yeah but I
thought it should have been funnier yeah
like it should have been crazier yeah it
should have been crazier definitely
should have been some [__] nude
scenes in it some sex yeah Tom's like no
boobs
yeah what kind of goes along with the
genre yeah it kind of adds more
authenticity to it you know if they were
trying to make was just kind of like gr
they did give you some down blouses and
[__] but yeah but it's but even the one
girl the one girl that got you know the
other girl that worked in the bakery the
Hispanic girl yeah yeah they they put
her in a in the freezer and like pulled
her out and she had like frosting all
over and she had like cherries on her
titties but then like when they moved
the frosting that she still had her
clothes on yeah so I was like oh okay so
we're not doing that but yeah there's no
nudity and like I said so it was a lot
of hanging around in the bakery right
talking and hiding from the little but
like I said I guess they didn't really
have a lot of money so right uh you but
what was missing is that there should
they should have been making out and
half new and like you know sex happened
and somebody gets killed yeah that's
what that's got to happen in in an
American horror movie yeah you got to
get killed for having sex yeah saw the
titties she gets killed yeah shame on
you that's the slasher rules right yeah
you should have never taken your shirt
off that's just yeah that's what that's
what
happens didn't pull your pants down
she'd still be
alive right yeah it's it's exactly like
that but yeah I so like I said I thought
I like the concept of this but the movie
was just okay yeah it was just okay like
it was fun but I didn't feel I wasn't
pissed off or anything yeah yeah it was
it it was satisfying it was entertaining
enough and like I liked the little
puppet like he was pretty cute but you
know like I said yeah and I I I did like
the kills bery Doughboy line okay that
actually made me laugh out loud but you
know because I was like oh okay that's
pretty funny but yeah overall it's like
I wish it had been funnier or like
crazier or like more over the top you
know I mean it almost seemed like it was
trying to be in Parts like a serious
movie kind of yeah which I don't think
they should have done that you know I
think they were just trying to knock
that [__] out I think they were just
trying to knock the movie out trying to
get the movie done it's barely over an
hour like I said it's 71 minutes I think
they were just trying to get the movie
done yeah I guess they were yeah but you
know it's it was pretty fun for all that
so then the other movie that we watched
we actually watched this one last night
this one's a lot better and we went
through shuter's unhappy holidays
section
and we had seen Andor reviewed pretty
much all the Christmas movies that were
in there except for this one because
they just added this one now I will note
that this movie I don't know if I'd call
it a Christmas horror it is said at
Christmas because everybody's got trees
everywhere and [__] like that but it's
like I don't think Christmas really
plays into the plot all that much
shoehorned that [__] in there to make
this a Christmas movie yeah I mean I
guess but it's just yeah it's not like a
Christmas like it's not like Santa Goan
aing people to death or nothing like
that it's just it happens to be
Christmas when all the stuff is going on
so you know I me so that's kind of why
they put so it's technically a Christmas
movie I guess so this called the brain
and it came out in
1988 and I had seen the cover for this
in the video store back in the day but I
never rented it and it's now I kind of
wish I had because this was actually
like way better than I was expecting it
it had a dumb cover I see that [__] I
was like I ain't [__] with that
the what they the problem is that they
showed you the monster right on the
cover and didn't look that good on the
cover so it just looked like a kids
movie but it's actually pretty good it
had some good ideas in it more kind of
like something along the lines
Cronenberg would have done yeah it g it
gave me a very Cronenberg Vibe yeah uh
it takes play they the shot at the the
uh C the Kodak headquarters up in Canada
so it has a real high-tech look to it
it's it's some film place there it looks
kind of
futuristic and uh there's like this
futuristic bu lab and they're making
this damn brain it's a brain creature
and the scientist that's making it is
the same scientist from um reanimator
reanimator and from Beyond yeah from
Beyond the older guy the guy who's
[__] his severed head was going down
on the chick that on Barbara kampton
yeah on barbaron was a great scene that
was a great scene it's epic scene man
epic scene in Hollywood history man the
well yeah like the first time I saw that
baby I'm like holy [__] severed head
going down on [__] some beautiful ass I
was like 22y old Barbara K yeah she's
going well yeah I mean wouldn't you yeah
holy [__] nobody want that to happen
that was pretty cool yeah but yeah just
like I love the audacity of that scene
it was just it was so great but yeah so
this has David Gail in it and
um so yeah it it gave me like uh like an
old cronenburg
meets oh like kind of like they live a
little bit it gave me a little bit of a
live kind of vibe cuz was the brain did
they wait did the dude make the brain or
no I thought they were
aliens I I really I'd have to watch it
again to get all the details I thought
it was they were growing it too weren't
they either that or that was like the
vat the vat that it had to live in and
then it jumped out of there and ate a
woman that was going to rat him out they
just let they just let her eat they just
sat there watched it while it ate her
and it got more powerful they got like
bigger like every time
it got bigger and it added people to its
Network it was like it was kind of like
something out of Invasion of the Body
Snatchers or something yeah it kind of
reminded me of that a little bit I don't
really understand what it was doing it
was adding their minds to it I think
that's what it was doing because it was
starting to control everybody's mind so
it was very much like Invasion of the
Body Snatchers in that way yeah but it's
weird because so yeah so what happens is
and it's almost kind of like a teen
movie too because you got like a bunch
of high school students and the main
character is this teenage guy named Jim
I think was his name and he's kind of a
troublemaker you know putting like
sodium tablets down the toilets and
blowing them blowing them up and stuff s
there for behavioral therapy yeah so
then there's this Behavioral Institute
called the what was it called the
psychiatric it was called PCI or
something like that and um become a free
taker yeah and then and then yeah so and
then David Gail also has like a local TV
show in this one town which I think is
called Meadow Veil and um it's called
independent thinking independent
thinking but it's kind of like a
brainwashing kind of show yeah um one
review I saw kind of compared it to like
Scientology like the stuff he was saying
which I guess is kind of like that it
goes very cronberg it's like you know
where the bad guys own companies and
they're working for you know they're
doing weird [__] paranormal and alien
[__] through company fronts yeah and
like trying to take over people's minds
so essentially the TV show
David Gail he's knows about this brain
obviously like whether he came to this
planet with the brain or whether CU they
turned out spoiler alert that he's not
human either right because they showed
that at the end but um so I don't know
if he came to Earth and like brought
this brain with him and we're going to
like but he has the show and he's going
to like hypnotize everybody so he's like
hypnotizing all these people and they're
just doing it in this one town and then
they're going to go Nationwide so like
at the end they're like oh you know the
show's going natural uhal
when they get people hypnotized to CU
you're led to assume the brain gets
bigger and bigger and bigger like as the
movie goes on it's not always just
eating people I think like as as he
absorbs people's minds or hypnotizes
them like it makes him more powerful so
he gets bigger because at the end that
scared the [__] out of me that scared
the [__] out of me but like um cuz at
the end it's not confined to its tank
anymore it's kind it can like you know
move around by itself I actually really
like the um the creature effects on this
I think the brain looks pretty cool yeah
it's all practical effects yeah he it's
just like a big huge green brain and
then a face comes out of it and it gets
bigger and it's just big teeth [__]
fangs on it it's just kind of like a
human face yeah it's cool looking so
it's like a monster movie but he's got
like tentacles and [__] and there and
when you get mind controlled by the
brain too like you start having
hallucinations and actually the opening
sequence of the movie was pretty great
because like this girl who you're you
find out later had been to this
institute like she starts having
hallucinations and she's like in her
room and like her teddy bear starts
crying blood and tentacles and [__] like
start coming out the walls and like the
walls start closing in and stuff like
that it was like a really good um
opening scene then you don't really know
the context of it like until later on
yeah she kills mom jumps out the window
yeah yeah and [__] like that so um but
then later on you find out that she went
there and they were like mind
controlling people and stuff but it it
did give me it's not like as serious or
as weird as a kinberg movie but it gave
me that same sort of vibe it's kind of
like if David Cronenberg had directed
like a teen horror movie kind of kind of
like night of the Comet that similar
tone yeah kind of like that kind of like
that so if David cornberg had directed
night of the Comet right and there was
an alien brain in it then it would kind
of be like this I thought the only
criticism I thought it went on slightly
too long like especially like some of
the chase scenes where they were kind of
chasing Jim around toward the end
because they kind of hypnotized
everybody in the town into thinking that
he was a murderer like that he had
killed people that he hadn't killed so
everybody was like so was kind of
becoming like a Witch Hunt like
everybody was like like it's Sam he's
the murderer you know what I mean so it
was that kind of [__] he's got this
little female sidekick running around
with him she's cute as [__] his
girlfriend she's wearing the 8est the
80s of the most 8est 80s outfit you ever
[__] seen it was it [__] was that
[__] was turqua it was I it's like Tom
said that I was like remember to say
that on the show he's like it's turqua
turqua cuz they all valley girl as
mother they would say turquoise it's
turqua it's turqu be like turquoise and
[__] pink stripes and everything
super big and baggy and I was like what
would that look like if somebody wore
that today [__] jny like crap like
you it looks like you went to the
[__] to to to the secondhand store
and bought that
yeah and like only a super skinny cute
little girl who's like 22 could P pull
that off anybody else You' look like a
big old bag in that [__] yeah everything
said that's what we were talking we got
off we got off in this whole long
tangent like because of this outfit
which was pretty incredible but um [__]
as [__] well the thing about that shirt
the pink and turqua one was that I'm
pretty sure that my cousin had almost
that exact shirt it might have been that
exact shirt it was kind of turtl necky
was it not and it had like big fat you
know pink and turqua Stripes that was
just I said no I'm going to say it like
like that forever so thanks um and then
she had a skirt on and then leggings
underneath that yeah and then socks and
then little tennis shoes tennis shoes
and then to this big huge baggy turqua
turqua yeah jacket yeah that was like
all the way down to her back of her
knees I think yeah back of her knees it
was big and kind of puffy yeah like a
like a h grenade jacket kind yeah I'm
like what my god with a big collar on it
and she's wearing that to like bust into
the the the insane asylum to bust her
boyfriend out which I got St [__] yeah
she did yeah I'm sitting there going
that is quite a girlfriend right there
she's like yeah bust you out of the
mental hospital that's the kind of
girlfriend you want right there she's
going to come get your ass out of there
cuz she knew something bad was going on
yeah she had a friend too oh can we say
too that one of the dudes in this that
plays one of the um like the the nurse
guy that's like the right-hand man of
David Gil is played by George buza and
he's in a [__] ton of stuff but as soon
as I saw him even though he was way way
way younger in this movie as soon as I
saw him I'm like oh my God it's Santa
from a Christmas horror story that
Anthology uh Christmas horror movie that
came out in 2016 and he's still he was
instantly recognizable I was like even
though this movie came out on 1988 so he
was obviously like much much younger but
I immediately was like hey it's the guy
that played Santa I mean he's been in a
ton of other stuff too he's in this a
lot actually yeah he's he's ended up
being like a main character yeah he's
kind of like the main henchman to the
bad guy yeah he was like so he was
always just kind of like kind like the
eigor yeah yeah kind of except like
eviler I guess but yeah so this was
actually a little bit um of a Hidden Gem
I thought like I said there was some
scenes that I thought kind of went on
slightly too long like some of the chase
scenes and stuff probably didn't need to
be but I think that was really the only
criticism I had yeah I thought you know
it's one I I I I couldn't believe I
hadn't seen it yeah me too remember in
the video at the store and I was like no
I don't want that one just kept passing
it up it was pretty good it kind of like
one I couldn't believe I saw that one
and I mentioned it earlier was fcking uh
night of the com I can't believe I
didn't see that I would have like that
also but um yeah you know caught him
later yeah at the time I didn't see him
I was oh we neglected to mention too
that um one of Jim's friends male
friends in the movie has the curliest
poofiest mest 80s hair that you just
have ever seen well and it's crazy
because the girlfriend has like you know
cuz in the 80s the girls had a big huge
poofy hair with like all the shellac on
it but her hair looked normal like it
you could wear it today and no one would
say it was just like it was just kind of
straight she had bangs and stuff like
that it didn't look dated or anything
that would probably considered to be
like a like a futuristic haircut yeah
maybe that's what it was that futuristic
looking haircut yeah but and that the
the guy's friend though he had like it
was
like it was uh something else they were
trying to look real stylish it kind of
looked like I I feel like John Taylor
from Duran Duran had hair like that for
a little while maybe not quite as poofy
but you seem like you're yeah sleepy
kind of yeah well you know we kind of
stay up and drank a lot last night cuz
it was Christmas Eve and so then I think
we slept till 10:30 yeah and got open
presents and then we've been stuff in
our faces all day you know what I mean
yeah get sleepy yeah but I mean we had
good Tom made a big ass ham and scallop
potatoes Brazilian cream corn got some
pies y got some rolls got all kind of
stuff down there sweet potatoes yeah
it's good but uh but yeah oh we got and
we got a bunch of booze for Yeah
Christmas too yeah a [__] ton yeah we'll
drink it we're not well not tonight we
can't drink it all tonight we'll drink
it up we'll drink it we'll die yeah if
we drank it all this evening but yeah
all right so uh yeah Tammy said don't
feel bad time I've never seen either of
these movies yeah yeah I mean these
these were the off-brand movies but
they're pretty good like I said Ginger
dead man you're probably not missing
much cuz I kind of feel like the concept
is funnier than the actual movie but
recommend the brain but the brain I
actually liked it I was like I it was a
lot better than I was expecting a lot
better than I was expecting yeah if you
want to watch a 80s movie you hadn't
seen it this was pretty good yeah it's
pretty decent and like I said it's
technically a Christmas movie because it
takes place on Christmas but it doesn't
really have anything to do with
Christmas but it's just kind of happens
around that time all right so I guess
we're going to wrap it up and maybe go
recover and I got to take the garbage
out oh yeah that's right cuz garbage
would normally come today but obviously
it's a holiday so we got to put it out
and we got all kind of garbage got all
kinds of boxes and paper and all kind of
[__] so yeah um hopefully have you guys
have a good uh rest of your Christmas
day and we will I don't know if I'm
going to stream tomorrow because I did
finish a book but I haven't um you know
so I don't know if I'm going to be ready
to do a stream tomorrow but if not I I
might do it on Thursday cuz I finally
finally finally finished reading slooh
foot sorry it took like so long for me
to finish it but yeah I finally finished
it so that's probably what the book
review will be so it'll either be
tomorrow or Thursday and then Wednesday
night uh Tammy will be very excited to
know that the show is going to be about
um the twin flames Universe cult okay
yeah so um yeah so actually we might
watch CU I think there's a couple
documentaries about that on Netflix that
we might want to watch okay yeah um you
know just impr preparation so yeah so
have a good rest of your Christmas you
guys and we will see you guys again
probably Wednesday